[Music]
great work this year
let's see your final projects since May
saving all the girls of the world
sweetheart you just made me drop out
this is my happy place
April stop your harness sometimes I feel
like screaming at the world here is a
plus plus plus Amanda no okay
come on don't be shy we show you this
again go on go get three of them sure Oh
[Music]
many calls like seven times and I've had
best day ever ties around this world is
this is a beautiful place I'm so happy
right is grape whoa his being life is
like a box of chocolates you never know
what you're gonna get
it's a great day it was awful
I got a guy's go over to end world
hunger all we need is more c4 why do any
seedless watermelon that's the problem
how you gonna make more watermelons if
you don't have your seat we gotta kill
the bees bees we all be dead this thing
it hurts and if you're hurt you need
more light
no bees no world hunger I hate me all
right we get a plane from LA to
Australia sprinkle food cool way and and
you seek the fish to get a watermelon Oh
groaning when he shoots his chicken and
will punish yourself here's what we need
to do we need to start a non-profit
raise a bunch of money participate in
the country in need and invest in
long-term sustainable solution I like
the idea with this one you know hey lady
hey you just saying oh we're just having
Girl Talk yeah no problem
you do anything I swear guys are just as
ghost Leonard it's all about them always
mom no it's nothing it feels really good
to finally be able to give you enough
money to pay off yeah they're lazy
they're so lazy yeah so friggin lazy you
never want to lift a finger
do you want to build that's what it is
my god you don't want to build they
don't want to build relationships
nothing you know what another thing I
came over the last night was wooed by me
what do i bench I'm sorry I just I can't
hear Gabby Oh our sand ate it or
something what I'm trying to get puppy I
want a puppy can we share along the
chair puppy oh so cute you like big
cuddle better than guys anyway
miss Amanda here you are your style
couscous no put it in the table oh my
god so good yeah no I can't take it
sorry mama
Oh mmm good
wait you gotta try this too I can't they
can't I can't ah see I knew you wanted
it now you can't have any here you are
the Murrell cancel and just too much
salt what is up guys it's Amanda Cerny
and thank you so much for watching sir
nice gift it really means the world to
me when you like and subscribe and all
that so now I am taking comments and
suggestions and ideas for skips from you
guys just comment it below I'm going to
choose one to do in next week's video
and I will announce the winner in the
video as well so bring on the comments
I'm reading them all and I can't wait to
see you guys next week mmm thankful